[Applause]
[Music]
let's start with a question and please
don't cheat and look it up on google how
many immigrants have been deported
by donald trump think about it during
the electoral campaign donald trump
couldn't have made his point more clear
he wouldn't accept any more illegal
immigrants
well check out this chart if you pay
attention you will see that deportations
wise obama was stricter on immigration
than
trump does this mean that trump loves
immigrants and deserves a nobel peace
prize
no in fact there are many nuances to
discuss about that chart but i wanted to
show it to you to make a point when it
comes to immigration words are one thing
and facts are a
totally different one so why are we
talking about any of this
well that's because of this
migrants at southern border top 100 000
for second month in a row
yeah you heard that right at the moment
the american continent is dealing with
one of the biggest refugee crises in
recent history but let's hear more
details about this
from eric of course simon in recent
years hundreds of thousands of central
american immigrants have been crossing
mexican territory until they reach the
border with the united states
many of them are children and women who
make the trip by foot and often arrive
malnourished
and sick
[Music]
and yes i said they cross mexican soil
because they come from central america
countries such as honduras guatemala and
el salvador
from many have become a living hell
there's violence
or drug gangs and of course in many
places there's extreme poverty
and these have caused people to flee
their homelands in search of a better
life
so now you might be wondering well how
did trump react to this challenge
well of course he did this
[Music]
donald trump threatens mexico with five
percent import tariff
over illegal immigration yeah yeah that
right donald trump wants to pass the hot
potato to mexico but here's the big
question
what does mexico do about it first of
all the mexican president
is the man you see on screen right now
that is andres manuel lopez obrador also
known as amlo
anglo is a hardcore left-wing politician
who you guessed it
is not a big fan of donald trump during
the electoral campaign
he said he would be compassionate with
immigrants crossing into his country
but now he says he's being pushed by the
white house to take a hard stance on
immigration
[Music]
you see mexico has a lot to lose if
america imposes tariffs on them
so amlo had to send in the troops to
stop the immigrants on the southern
border so
again evil donald trump is pushing a
poor good-hearted politician to do his
dirty work
right well this is the narrative you
often hear
on many media outlets but is it really
that simple so there's a big question
i mean what would be the big deal if
mexico just took in more refugees
i mean similar arrangements have been
made with other countries like turkey
and
they seem to work but here's the thing
have you ever wondered
about the immigration policy in mexico
well you should
here are some numbers 14 of the u.s
population are immigrant the oecd
average is 13
but mexico has just one percent yep yeah
that right
mexico is not a country for foreigners
so today's question is well
how does mexican immigration policy
actually work what is mexico actually
doing to manage the refugee crisis
are they really doing what trump wants
well today we're going to answer all of
these questions but as
always before we do we gotta take a look
back at the history
[Music]
the migrant caravan i know what you're
thinking now
why are so many central americans
leaving their countries right now well
let's be honest here honduras
guatemala and el salvador have not
exactly been history's prosperous
countries but
if we have learned anything from history
it's that what can go bad
can go even worse between 2010 and 2012
the crime rates absolutely skyrocketed
honduras suffered coup d'etat in 2009 el
salvador is suffering street violence
from the so-called morass or
street gangs something similar is
happening in guatemala and part of it
can be explained
because of drug trafficking
[Music]
you see during the 80s narco-violence
was focused on colombia you
definitely knew that those were the
times of pablo escobar the cali cartel
and farc
but after 2000 colombia managed to
reduce the violence yep cocaine
production is still going on there but
the cartels have
reached a sort of pax mafiosa they are
still doing the drug business but they
don't kill each other anymore
but now a similar kind of drug violence
has moved to other parts of the
continent
also some people blame climate change
according to this theory climate change
is creating droughts in central america
if the crops aren't productive people
starve and have to leave
add to this ngos like pueblos sin
fronteras which
organized the so-called migrant caravans
they offer logistical support to
thousands of migrants to start their
journeys to the u.s border
but of course it's not only about ngos
it's also
about those human traffickers
[Music]
so as you can see there are many
explanations but the truth
is that there is an exodus for a better
understanding in 2007 u.s border patrol
apprehended 16
000 guatemalans 11 years later in 2018
the figure increased to 116
000. and now you might be wondering well
are these immigrants or
are they refugees and to be fair we
should only really talk about refugees
here now officially they are considered
economic migrants but let's be honest
these are not ambitious people trying to
achieve the american dream in most cases
they're just people escaping
extreme violence in many cases they're
women and children who are threatened by
a marrow or a drug gang they would
almost certainly be killed if they went
back
this is why they will do whatever it
takes to leave
and i say whatever it takes because they
really do take no prisoners there are
more than 3
000 kilometers that's 1 800 miles
between
guatemala and el paso texas many of
these migrants they do the journey
by foot others do it by the so-called
death train and you can imagine why they
call it that
[Music]
so what happens when these people cross
the border well most of them are just
apprehended and deported to their home
countries but let's be
fair here some make it to america u.s
authorities
have already created many programs to
attend to those refugees
in 2017 more than 59 000 central
americans stayed in the country well is
that too much or too little well
it's up to you to make your own judgment
on that one but the question is
how many did mexico accept we don't have
an exact number
but it is much smaller and here's what
we know in mexico today
there are about 50 000 guatemalans while
the united states
hosts nine hundred thousand
so you might be wondering now well why
why can't central american refugees
remain in mexico let's have a look shall
we
no country for foreigners in mexico they
have made it very clear not all migrants
are made equal for example if you are
watching this video from america
do not worry mexico will welcome you
with the most
open of arms in fact most of the
migrants living there they come from the
united states
don't believe me have a look at this
chart
[Music]
mexico has 1.2 million of these migrants
today
of course 900 000 are american 27 000 to
spanish and
only 15 000 come from honduras mexico
has more
germans than it does salvadorians and
this is surprising considering the
salvadorians are
much closer they speak the same language
and are
leaving their country by the thousands
so you might be wondering
why is this is it pure chance do central
americans not like mexico
of course not just look at what mexican
immigration law says
[Applause]
the secretary of state can deny entry to
a foreigner
into his country or change the
characteristics of their migrant status
at any time if the demographic balance
requires it
yup you heard that right this
demographic balance is just a nice way
of saying
if you're poor you're not allowed to
live here and when it says changing the
characteristics of their migrant status
it basically means that they can just
tell you to [ __ ] off whenever they like
all right i know you might be thinking
things are changing
and of course they are just like what
the former mexican president said in
october of 2018.
today mexico gives you its hand we want
you
and all the migrants to feel protected
and calm
down in order to support you today
mexico is launching the feel like home
plan is
the man you see on screen is enrique
pena nieto the former mexican president
this was one of his last policies before
leaving office
his successor amlo agreed with this plan
and donald trump he also agreed all of a
sudden his southern neighbor accepted
migrants so america didn't have to
but hold on a minute as we said at the
beginning words are one thing and facts
are another
sure at the beginning the mexican
government accepted people from central
america
in a few months more than 20 000
guatemalans hondurans and salvadorians
came to the country asking for a visa
and how did the mexicans like that big
surprise not very much
[Music]
according to a survey 58 percent of
mexicans don't want migrants entering
the country
exactly trump is not alone in hating
migrants and refugees
add to that the fact that the mexican
authorities can't deal with so many
people crossing the southern border by
the way
i mean think about it you need to build
shelters print those visas and feed all
of those people and you need
money for that and you need political
capital and the new mexican president he
doesn't want to risk any of those things
he's extremely popular and he doesn't
want to stop being popular
so with mexican society against migrants
and the army and the police with
no resources the new mexican president
had only
one choice
mexico triples deportations of central
americans with lopez obrador
the new government has removed more than
45 000 people in five months
15 000 of those were in april now you
might be wondering what
are the consequences of this policy of
course the biggest victims
are those hundreds of thousands of
central americans who cannot stay in
mexico or in america this is not the
only consequence
think about it if amlo doesn't want the
refugees where are they going to go
exactly they're going to keep making
their way to the united states the land
of the free
so the hot potato it falls right back
into donald trump's hands
it is then in may of 2019 that the white
house threatens mexico with five percent
tariffs
in other words this is when the mexican
government finds itself between the
hammer and the anvil if the mexican
president
takes in so many refugees the mexicans
are gonna hate him and if he doesn't
well donald trump is gonna punish him
so what's his solution
[Music]
the u.s governments remain in mexico
policy is expanding
stranding more people in a dangerous
mexican city
in other words in may of 2019 trump went
to allah and said
look uh mexico dude i don't give two
shits about what you do with your
central americans it's
really not my problem you want to take
them they're all yours want to deport
them whatever dude
you could deport them i don't give a
[ __ ] canada
russia [ __ ] mars it's on you bro
just one thing i don't want to see those
[ __ ] crossing
my border and if i do you're gonna pay
for it hombre
that's right you're gonna pay so what
was the easiest
solution to amlo basically letting all
those immigrants stay
in a ghetto mexico has deployed 6 000
troops to contain them so they haven't
been deported but they cannot continue
on their way to integrate into mexican
society for example in the most recent
of months many of those immigrants have
been concentrated in cities like
nueva laredo at the border with the us
and they're in really poor conditions by
the way
big shocker there are no doctors there's
no food and violence it's starting to
rise up
[Music]
the worst place of all is the city of
tapachula at the border with guatemala
over twenty thousand and thirty thousand
asylum pledges have been registered here
and the mexican army has been stationed
there stopping people from going any
further north oh and yeah
lots of murders are already happening so
in other words those refugees ended up
in the same situation that they were
escaping from
neither america or mexico wants them and
while those two countries just keep
throwing our potato to one another these
people
are dying
so the question now goes to you how do
you think this problem can be solved do
you think mexico could do
anything to accept the refugees or is it
really only america's job could they
really reach a deal to share
responsibility well please leave your
answer in the comment section below also
visit reconsider media.com that's the
podcast that provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine
don't forget we publish brand new videos
every week so subscribe hit that bell
hit that like button
all of that good stuff and i'll see you
next time and if you want to learn more
about politics and hear
even more of my lovely voice you can
join us at reconsider media we have a
podcast at reconsider media.com
podcast see you there